Her low freak bitches.
Are you in an unmanageable position now though?
As far as like responding to people because like I try to respond to people,
but I can't.
It's not possible.
I would imagine like the over the last few months it must be just overwhelming.
Yeah.
Well I've given up trying to keep up on my email.
It's just not,
my wife helps me out.
I've had some other people helped me,
but you know what I do is I,
I look and I tried to say thank you to people and write them a couple of lines
when I have a moment.
But you know,
because I can't get to all of it.
They just come in by the,
so I know that position.
Right.
And it's too bad because people are writing me very heartfelt long letters.
They're often brilliant,
frequently,
like amazing letters telling me,
you know,
their experiences with the authoritarian left or,
or,
or the way they've been cornered in,
in one way or another or,
or how starting to clean up the room changed their life.
That's quite fun because it's something I always tell people to do instead of
going out and protesting Jesus.
I just can't stand up the room.
Yeah.
Meaning,
well,
my sense is is that if you want to change the world,
you start from yourself and work outward because you build your competence that
way.
It's like,
I don't know how you can go out and protest the structure of the entire economic
system if can't keep your room organized.
Yeah.
Isn't that an issue with people though,
that they always want to enact some sort of control over the outside world when
they're inside is all fucked up.
Yeah.
It was also people that are the most adamant about it.
Well,
I think there's some truth in that.
Um,
I think there is truth in that.
I mean,
people try to change the outside world for lots of ways,
but many of those ways aren't just pure good.
But you know,
I've thought about,
well,
I made a video call which was called message to millennials where I was,
it was called how to change the world properly.
A bit of a,
on the pretentious side I suppose.
But,
um,
I was trying to produce something that was a counter position to this idea that
what you should do is go out and fix up other people.
You know,
that's just not right.
And there's a new testament line about that.
Something about,
you know,
not worrying too much about the log in your neighbor's eye or about the speck in
your neighbor's eye when you have a log in your eye.
So like,
yes,
no kidding,
but you know,
do you really want to,
do you really want to face that?
And so what I've thought about is that,
well,
what you start to do is you start to tell and act out the truth locally,
like within the domain of your actual competence.
You know,
cause the world presents itself as a series of puzzles,
some of which you're capable of solving and some of which you're not.
And you have many puzzles in front of you that you could solve,
but you choose not to.
You know that those are the things that weigh on your conscience.
It's like,
you know why I should really do this?
But you don't.
It's like,
so I had this idea a long time ago because the world is a pretty dreadful place.
I thought,
well what would the world be like if people stopped avoiding the things they
knew they should do?
You know?
Cause the question is how much are we contributing to the fact that life is a,
is an existential catastrophe and a tragedy?
How much is our own corruption contributing to that?
How to really worthwhile question things.
You leave undone because you're angry,
you're resentful,
you're lazy,
you have a neuro Shia,
well you consult your conscience and it says,
well,
you know,
that place over there could use a little work.
It's the same as working on yourself.
And so you clean that up because you can,
and then things are a little clearer around you and you're a little better off
because you've practiced a bit and,
and so you're little stronger.
And then in something else manifest itself and says,
well maybe you could like take a crack at fixing me up too.
So he decided to do that.
And then that gets a little bit more pristine,
you know,
and soon.
And it's,
it's humble because you're not exceeding your domain of competence.
You know,
it's like don't be fixing up the economy.
18 year olds,
you don't know anything about the economy.
It's a massive,
complex machine beyond anyone's understanding.
And you mess with it at your peril.
So when can you even clean up your own room?
No.
Well,
you should think about that.
You should think about that.
Cause if you can't even clean up your own room,
who the hell are you to give advice to the world?
That's so very,
very important thing for people to hear.
[inaudible].